ja die vier Tage Woche oder 30 Stunden
Woche bei vollem Lohn und
personalausgleich ist ein zeitgemäßes
Modell für eine zukunftsorientierte
Arbeitswelt wir brauchen Arbeitszeiten
die zum Leben passen es gibt bereits
zahlreiche Beispiele wo das eingeführt
wurde die sehr sehr gut laufen in Island
Arbeiten 90% der Angestellten bereits in
einer 4 Tage Woche es gibt einen großen
Modellversuch in Großbritannien der sehr
positiv ausgewertet wurde die
Gewerkschaft IG Metall fordert das jetzt
auch für die Stahlindustrie das ist also
kein irgendwie utopischer Wahnsinn und
in Island ist jetzt auch nicht die
Wirtschaft davon zusammengebrochen das
heißt es ist sehr realistisch dass wir
das in den nächsten Jahren durchsetzen
ich will drei Argumente nennen weshalb
eine vier Tage Woche sehr sinnvoll ist
erstens die Beschäftigten wollen es also
80% der Beschäftigten können sich
vorstellen in einer vier Tage Woche bei
vollem Lohn und personalausgleich zu
arbeiten die Frauen wollen tendenziell
laut Umfragen bisschen mehr arbeiten ja
die sind oft in Teilzeit die Männer
wollen ein bisschen weniger Zeiten das
wäre sehr gerecht diese Arbeit besser zu
verteilen weil zu Hause steht ja
meistens noch die zweite Schicht Arbeit
an also die unbezahlte Arbeit
Kindererziehung waschen putzen und so
weiter das machen meistens die Frauen
und da würden wir den Männern auch ein
bisschen Gelegenheit geben damit
anzupacken und umgekehrt ist es so dass
ich finde dass Väter auch ein Recht
darauf haben ihre Kinder aufwachsen zu
sehen bevor die schon wieder ausziehen
das zweite Argument ist wir haben 2021
circa 180.000 burnout-erkrankungen in
Deutschland gehabt das ist irrsinnig
viel das zeigt dass wir da Umsteuern
müssen mit Entlastungen mit besserer
Arbeit weil nur gesunde Beschäftigte
sind auch gute Mitarbeiter und der
dritte Punkt ist volkswirtschaftlich
beschäftigungspolitisch wir können da
ähm Arbeitslosigkeit entgegenwirken mit
einer 4 Tage Woche weil wir Arbeit
einfach gerechter verteilen und wir
können auch Arbeitsplätze sichern das
hat VW auch bewiesen 1993 hat VW eine
vier Tage Woche eingeführt um eben
Arbeitsplätze zu sichern rund um das ist
ein guter Vorschlag es spricht nichts
dagegen und wir sollten eine 4 Tage
Woche in Deutschland einführen also hier
wurde heftig mitgeschrieben Notizen
gemacht und ich glaube er hätte immer
sitzt schon in den Startlöchern bei
diesem Thema ja nicht höre Arbeit
gerechter verteilen wir können was
machen gegen die Arbeitslosigkeit ich
weiß nicht sie reden über Deutschland
wenn wir gleich vielleicht noch ein
Wasser trinken oder vielleicht auch ein
Glas Bier und gehen mal raus Berlin
nicht nur Mitte sondern auch darüber
hinaus haben sie Restaurants wo dran
steht geschlossen fehlendes Personal die
machen zum Teil mittags zu das ist nicht
nur in Berlin so sondern im gesamten
Land wir haben in der gesamten Breite
bis zum letzten Handwerkern
Fachkräftemangel und ein
Arbeitskräftemangel in der Logistik ja
im Restaurantbereich wie es gesagt hatte
Hotel und so weiter das heißt dieses
Argument ist völlig aus der Zeit erster
Punkt zweiter Punkt die vier Tage Woche
gibt es ja also die Flexibilität sollte
da sein das Problem ist nur bei ihrem
Vorschlag dass sie als Politik sagen wir
machen einfach mal acht Stunden weniger
bei vollem ausgleichen dieses Land ist
groß geworden weil es eine
Tarifautonomie gibt und wenn bei VW
IG Metall mit den Arbeitgebern
verabschiedet das ist eine 35 Stunden
Woche gibt dann ist das völlig in
Ordnung aber schauen sich mal an was in
anderen Ländern passiert wenn die
Politik sich in die Arbeitsmarktpolitik
einmischt das ist Sache der Tarifpartner
und da haben sie sich rauszuhalten und
der letzte Punkt ich finde es echt gut
wenn man arbeiten nicht immer so
schlecht darstellt auch dieser Begriff
Balance als ob Arbeit schlecht ist und
live ist gut wirklich dass das muss wir
müssen natürlich die Arbeitsbedingungen
verbessern Gesundheitsschutz vieles mehr
nur wenn in diesem Lande Arbeiten nichts
mehr wert ist dann dann dann
erwirtschaften sie nichts mehr dann
haben sie kein Sozialstaat mehr kein
Rentensystem kein Gesundheitssystem das
muss doch alles finanziert werden
ihre Argumente verbringen also klares
Nein hör ich raus zu viel Tage Woche das
aber gehört auch bei ihm
ja klar ich war Mathematik nicht ganz
gut ich hatte eine drei befriedigend
aber das reicht aus diese Möglichkeit zu
sagen weniger arbeiten
für das gleiche Geld
funktioniert nicht quod errate
demonstrandem sie laden wir unternehmen
können so quasi auch nicht profitabel
arbeiten können sich nicht halten sie
glauben ja natürlich
eine halbe Stunde jetzt gerade über die
Probleme des Fleischers über der über
den Bäcker über die Kneipen und und und
und weil du ansprichst Logistik ich
glaube 8000 Lastwagenfahrer fehlen die
notwendig sind um dieses Land zu
versorgen also wir haben zu wenige
Menschen in Arbeit
und jetzt sollen die die da sind noch
weniger arbeiten das funktioniert nicht
Hoffnung ist ja dass man eben genau
damit auch Anreize schafft für Menschen
sich dann auch bei diesen Firmen zu
bewerben die BVG beispielsweise heute
hat gesagt wir werden uns nämlich ganz
entziehen können und wir hoffen dass wir
mehr Menschen dadurch bekommen
also ich denke auch man kann schlecht
Unternehmen vorschreiben dass sie dann
sozusagen die die Arbeitszeit verkürzen
von fünf auf vier Tage und den gleichen
Lohn bezahlen denn das ist wenn ich es
richtig überschlagen wurde 20%
Lohnerhöhung und das mal eben schnell so
dass glaube ich wird viele Betriebe
überfordern ich denke schon aber man
kann es wahrscheinlich auch nicht nur an
einer Schraube drehen sondern man muss
eine sozusagen das ist ein komplexes
Phänomen mit dem Mangel an
Arbeitskräften und ich glaube das kann
man auch nicht mit einer eigenen
Schraube sozusagen wieder zurechtbiegen
ich finde den Ansatz den sie vorher
schon vorgetragen haben gar nicht so
verkehrt zu sagen wir wollen all die die
keine Arbeit haben unterstützen auf
finanziell aber warum können denn die
die seelisch und körperlich dazu in der
Lage sind dann nicht gleichzeitig auch
für die Gesellschaft etwas tun denn das
also ich glaube das hätte sogar mehrere
positive Effekte und dieses Modell
schwebt mir eigentlich schon seit
längerem vor obwohl ich keine positiv
ist vielleicht das möchte ich hier an
dem Tisch auch mal diskutieren weil wir
hier auch eine spannenden Runde
zusammensetzen eine Generationenfrage
die Generation Z die ganz klar sagt die
work-fans wurde angesprochen und dann
sind immer mir ist Arbeiten einfach
nicht mehr so wichtig ich setze andere
Prioritäten können Sie es nachvollziehen
hatten ich kann es nicht nachvollziehen
aber ich nehme es zur Kenntnis die Welt
dreht sich ich hatte auch mal andere
ideale als das junge Menschen heute
haben ähm ich wenn ich rückblickend bin
dann gibt's den schönen Satz früher war
alles besser ich habe aber dazu gelernt
und weiß das eine beschissene Gegenwart
nach dem Laufe einiger Jahre zu guten
alten Zeit wird wenn man darüber erzählt
so also es ergibt sich weiter die
Technik hat sich weiterentwickelt ich
war auch beim beim Fußball zum Beispiel
ja wenn wir uns Spiele anschauen von
1972 oder 54 das ist die besten
deutschen Mannschaften waren aller
Zeiten wie man den Umfragen dann liest
und sie sich das heute an das ist ein
Unterschied wie Tag und Nacht so hat
sich das Leben verändert so hat sich die
Arbeit verändert und so hat sich das
jetzt verändert aber die
Grundrechnungsarten bleiben und deswegen
bleibe ich dabei weniger Arbeit für das
gleiche Geld funktioniert nicht
dann würde ich da vielleicht mal drauf
eingehen also man kann ja zurückschauen
im 19 Jahrhundert wurden 16 Stunden
Arbeitstage gearbeitet es gab keinen
Urlaub es gab keine Krankenversicherung
es gab ja es gab Kinderarbeit so also es
wurde früher viel viel mehr gearbeitet
und den Leuten ging es viel beschissener
wir haben aber sowas wie eine
Produktivkraft Entwicklung also wir
haben technische Entwicklung die Skills
der Leute haben sich weiterentwickelt
und wir haben kontinuierlich eine
Reduktion von Arbeitszeit gehabt bei
einer gleichzeitigen Prosperität also es
ist ja gewachsenen Leuten geht das
besser und das Argument zählt nicht das
sozusagen weniger Arbeit dann dazu führt
dass alles den Bach runtergeht das
zeigen auch alle Studien die gemacht
wurden wohne vier Tage Woche eingeführt
wurden
ich kann auch auf die
betriebswirtschaftliche Ebene gehen die
Produktivität der Beschäftigten in der
vier Tage Woche steigt sogar das heißt
nicht mal die Unternehmen hätten
irgendeinen vernünftigen Grund zu sagen
ja jetzt arbeiten unsere Mitarbeiter
aber nicht mehr und jetzt werden die
alle faul sondern die sind sozusagen
noch effizienter verordnen wenn die
Firma VW drauf kommen und sagt wir reden
uns das mal aus wir machen das warum
wollen sie es verordnet dagegen gehe ich
vor die Firma Huber mit in Firmen
besitzt privat besitzt
jetzt bin ich dran jetzt
auf die Frauenrolle zurück oder wenn wir
gleichzeitig kriegen verschiedene
ich bin verheiratet die Frau meine Frau
hat promoviert an der Uni an der sie
noch das machen wollen also reden sie
mir keine andere
frauenhaltung und gerade weil ich das
tue muss man ja auch mal fragen was ist
Arbeit sie haben gesagt Arbeit wird
abgewertet aber ist es keine Arbeit wenn
eine Frau zu Hause zwei Kinder erzieht
wenn jemand zu Hause noch die alten
pflegt weil man die irgendwie nicht ins
Pflegeheim geben will sie haben vorhin
gesagt Arbeit wird abgewertet wenn man
eine 4 Tage Woche einführt und das halte
ich für dich habe nein ich habe gesagt
wir können uns nicht nur auf dem Erbe
und dem Fleiß unserer Elterngeneration
ausruhen es muss hier in Leuten es muss
hier noch in Deutschland müssen noch
Leute müssen noch Leute da sein die auch
Straßen bauen und Brücken und dem
Handwerk unterwegs sind die Ideen haben
und die umsetzen wirklich gehen Sie doch
mal raus die Leute fehlen es schließen
die die Handwerker schließen ähm die die
Restaurants schließen alles macht zu
sie müssen doch das erstmal
erwirtschaften was glauben Sie denn
unser Rentensystem unser Sozialsystem
Pflegesystem Gesundheitssystem das muss
doch alles finanziert werden der macht
das denn in Zukunft ja ich habe schon
gesagt die Wertschöpfung das machen die
Beschäftigten und nicht irgendwie die
die sie mit ihrer Politik da als CDU
irgendwie gepampert haben ja aber die
die Sache ist doch wieso glauben sie
dass mehr Leute einen Beruf ergreifen
wenn man den unattraktiver macht die
vier Tage Woche wäre in Attraktivität
Signal aber das kann doch heute machen
an die Leute irgendwie in diesem das
kann ich ich habe drei Jahre Kollegen
das kann ich habe bei mir drei Jahren
Kollegen im Büro gehabt der hat nur vier
Tage gearbeitet weil an einem Tag hat er
promoviert und vierter gearbeitet weil
der so gut war wegen mir kann auch
jemand kommen nur zwei Tage aber der
kriegt dann halt auch das Geld was sie
zusteht für diese zwei Tage und Sie
können als Politik nicht einfach sagen
so mal ich mir die Welt und dann
funktioniert